Hey Thoughty2 here.
Humans have an uncanny ability to make out
shapes and faces in the dark that aren’t
really there.
We do this because our brain is deprived of
visual information to form a complete picture,
because, well…
it’s dark.
So our brain simply fills in the blanks without
telling us.
Cheers brain, thanks for keeping me up at
night wondering why my wall clock suddenly
looks like a creature from the X-Files.
But the fact that we see things in the dark
that aren’t really there, isn’t the reason
we’re afraid of the black of the night.
So what is?
Let’s find out.
We are most afraid of the dark when we’re
four to six years old.
This fear tapers off by the time we reach
the age of nine, but it never truly goes away.
Some adults are considerably more afraid of
the dark than others, but there’s a part
of all of us that has an apprehension towards
dark places.
In a poll, 40% of adults admitted to feeling
scared walking around their own home in the
dark.
And 10% of adults are too afraid of the dark
to even get out of bed if the lights aren’t
on.
A severe fear of the dark is called nyctophobia.
If you’re particularly afraid of the dark,
you might think it could help to sleep with
the lights on.
But you may unwittingly be doing harm to your
brain.
A study at Ohio State University discovered
that sleeping with the lights on, damages
your brain and increases the likelihood of
depression.
This is because when its dark our brain produces
a hormone called Melatonin.
Created in the pineal gland, melatonin helps
to regulate your body’s sleep cycle.
When we don’t get enough sleep or sleep
in a room that isn’t entirely dark, our
melatonin production is severely inhibited.
Over time a lack of melatonin can have negative
consequences on our body.
Such as: Your brain will age faster.
Melatonin depravation speeds up the rate at
which your brain ages.
Researchers think that the elderly often have
more trouble sleeping because their brain
doesn’t produce as much melatonin as younger
individuals.
Which may also contribute to the degradation
of brain function that some people suffer
from, during old age.
A lack of melatonin can also lead to a condition
known as S.A.D., short for Seasonal Affective
Disorder.
SAD is associated with sufferers of depression.
Sufferers of SAD have an altered schedule
for melatonin release.
SAD suffers don’t produce melatonin until
later on in their sleep cycle, meaning they
get less melatonin overall.
This can eventually lead to worsening depression,
bipolar disorder, eating disorders and schizophrenia.
Melatonin deprivation has also been linked
to increases in blood pressure and cancer
rates.
Health concerns aside, it’s a damn good
job that we are afraid of the dark, and you
shouldn’t be ashamed of it, because believe
it or not, being scared has its advantages.
Especially when it’s dark.
Human kind’s fear of the darkness stems
from the days of early humanity, long before
we evolved into modern humans.
You see, humans haven’t always been at the
top of the food chain.
Before the advent of the hunter-gatherer,
and for quite a while afterwards, us humans
were the hunted ones.
Our earliest human-like ancestors first appeared
around seven million years ago.
Although, humans didn’t first step foot
off the African continent and into the Middle
East, until 1.75 million years ago.
That’s a long, long time that humans had
to defend themselves against the myriad of
natural threats that they shared the African
planes with.
Until we learnt to defend ourselves, humans
were under constant threat from animals such
as lions, hippos, crocodiles, rhinos and snakes.
Our early human ancestors didn’t stand a
chance against a pride of lions, without modern
tools or shelter.
This problem was made even worse during the
night.
Predators used the pitch black of the night
to their advantage.
A lonely defenseless human wandering the planes
of Africa didn’t stand a chance in the dark.
After all, lions and other predators can see
in the dark considerably better than humans.
In fact, 60% of lion attacks in Tanzania between
1988 and 2009 were between the dark hours
of 6pm and 9:45pm.
Because of this, humans developed an instinctive
fear of the dark.
That feeling of anxiousness you get when you’re
trekking through a dark place is an ancient
reaction that humans have developed to warn
us, that dark places are dangerous.
Especially so, because in the dark, we can’t
see where we’re going and we have no idea
what hostile creature might be coming towards
us.
The emotion that is anxiety is just a tool
our body uses to get the job done and that
job is keeping us safe in the dark.
Over millions of years this fear has been
fine tuned by both nature and nurture to keep
us safe from the perils of the night.
You see it’s not just natural selection
that enforces this fear.
Millions of years of children seeing their
parents become afraid when going out at night,
and more recently, mother’s telling their
children not to go out past eight o’clock,
has helped to reinforce and improve human
kind’s ability to stay anxious and fearful
of the dark.
This ability may not be as relevant nowadays,
because we no longer have to contend with
ferocious wild animals on a daily basis.
But even in our modern world, the night still
holds many threats, mostly of the human variety.
So we should be very thankful for our fear
of the dark, because it offers at least a
modicum of protection, constantly reminding
us not to tread where danger may lurk.